[Music]
goodmorning reject nation I'm Greg Alba
I'm John Humphrey I'm Andrew Gordon no
five minutes sketch this time I'm sure
1.8 K of you are very happy about that
today
that last sketch took a couple weeks to
prepare you know we just we just heard
about this now that's why we don't have
one today maybe they'll be one for the
review if I'm able to think of something
in time
wait Greg you mean it doesn't actually
take only a few minutes to make a sketch
you actually have to work hard it takes
a few weeks you're ridiculous man nobs
lied that's a twenty minutes to film
that that makes more sense
anywhoo avengers endgame the next
trailer I'm excited to do this so early
in the morning here [ __ ] yeah hop into
it before we go into that I want to say
thank you to everyone who's been
following us over at our patreon page if
we're not your favorite youtubers but if
you have a youtube channel that is your
favorite that has a patreon page go
ahead and show them some support by
following them over there as far as our
patreon page goes what we do over there
consistently as we do weekly Q&A s as
well as TV show reactions stream alongs
for many shows I did all of attack on
Titan John does Full Metal Alchemist
Brotherhood my hero academia one punch
man Gotham just started up haunting of
Hill House supernatural and we also
feature reaction highlights with footage
included for several shows and who's one
punch man supernatural my hero academia
and as of late Full Metal Alchemist
Brotherhood and this guy also does
plenty of music video reactions so go
ahead and follow us over at our patreon
page today and last thing we will be
doing a breakdown of this trailer it's
easy to miss stuff when you're doing a
reaction for the first time they'll do a
video in a couple hours where we are
talking more in-depth about stuff in the
trailer so keep a lookout for that
upload guys let's get into this
[Music]
thousand years ago I know where that
cave became mine man we must I love you
then you said you were surprises but
absolutely hope it'll last one last one
am i right
[Music]
time travel
the poachers
[Music]
[Music]
I love their symbolism with the red
[Music]
Thunder
[Music]
even if there's a chance
to try
at red area
haha
wherever it takes it's like a Michael
Douglas a man the loss of one around see
alot of Robinson's yeah
I called it knew they would put her in
the next trailer for sure no shot at us
no shot of Thanos - tag whatever tape
that might have been nebulae who is
going after him that okay one more time
you know you know how we do you know how
we do I really love this coming full
circle thing of your teasing yeah and in
the original team know their first moves
it's this far away not to show a lot of
yeah good point
the Benatar's
I mean I feel like it's gonna be pepper
who pulls off the surprise of the suit
that's prime I badges by the BIA let's
see where we see them disappear yeah
meanwhile back
[Music]
I love this like black and white with
the red symbolism yeah yeah it's great
rightio shimmers with spit
[Music]
[Music]
what's her hair and her hair was blonde
in the other trailers are i6 lightning
you notice the time just the time
elapsed and time comes out it's also
caps got a beard a doesn't
where our is he there
yeah did she say it has to be pleasure
killings got a house in this movie owner
and there everyone's going to work
where's my favorite shop the Super Bowl
spot they're all silhouetted here yeah
so he makes it back to her
I thought they were really gonna be
there the whole mother
I love this moment
[Music]
[Music]
when he does that I don't it harkens
back to the first Avengers film when he
does end like he's waiting for Hulk he's
about to beat him and then he it's like
it's a reversal yeah yeah yeah yeah you
know I'm so excited for this one because
as as a personal as infinity war evolved
into over the course of the film what I
loved about the ending of infinity war
is that you realize oh this film is
exceptionally more personal because at
first when it as it's going you're like
oh it's another adventure it's really
like a personal adventure and then it
becomes really personal by the time it
ends and the reason why this one gets me
so pumped is because from the very
beginning that this movie starts it's
gonna have all this epic dark it's gonna
be the most personal Avengers Assemble
film that we've ever gotten for sure
because the threat levels so much there
and the marketing that they're doing for
this film is so smart you know like I
doubt this is all the first 15 to 20
minutes like that's all they're showing
here there's that it's got to be cool
like especially with time jumps and
everything that's gotten like Tony being
back there there's a better sure most of
this is within the first 15 20 minutes
man not those epic moments that one
sequence obviously nebula Captain
America
Baca Diana rocky and Jim Renault it's
war machines like that whole sequence
right there I'm sure I feel like that's
gonna be in tribute to the sequence in
the Infinity Gauntlet moment where
they're all fighting we're all going up
against Thanos was like is like one of
the cosmic battles before I don't want
to spoil anything here because it
happens in the Infinity Gauntlet comic
so I'm like maybe I shouldn't say
certain things because of what happens
there but it seems very much in tribute
to that specific moment oh yeah John I
mean this trailer just really caught me
with the tone again I mean I love the
choice of bringing in all the scenes
from the old movies that we've seen
before how far that we've come I love
that we're sticking with the somberness
we're sticking with the desperation yeah
even just adding one shot to that moment
like everyone freaked out the first time
with caps and and you got trap's the
shield on and even getting that one shot
of his face out on the bed
yeah looking all nasty it's kind of
pretty very Saving Private Ryan like you
know what yeah I'd like to shake you the
hand like it looks like his old suit
it's the og shield - yeah yeah and so
you know they've got me disoriented but
they've got me really sucked into the
tone yeah I appreciate that because yeah
this looks very personal both from a
standpoint of we lost all of our friends
but also it's like we they got to be
feeling failure we got to do something
and that's very palpable and I also
quantum realm exploration like for
people who are like do it really do you
see a man and the wasp I think you do
yeah it's probably better if you watch
the whole movie might get a little more
you know in the quantum realm works and
now the shot of a male walking around
like yeah but yeah we'll do a full
breakdown in a second yeah but yeah just
really quickly harping on the way you
guys said I really enjoyed the tone of
this I'd like had the somber feeling at
the beginnig obviously what happened if
anywhere I love the color palette out
it's all dark and you only get the red
colour and and and also too I just
really love how there like he said
they're going full circle showing you
know previous films you know just
harmony back to the original team and we
kind of sent in the first trailer that
when Toni and nebula are stuck on the
the Benatar cuz the first ones the
Milano this one's the Benatar it really
feels like again he's just stuck in that
cave he's gotta figure out a way out of
this without using the Iron Man suit I
mean even though we kind of used the
Iron Man suit to get advocated but you
know I mean he's gotta rely more on his
brain to get out of the situation but
awesome Elsa - wouldn't shall we didn't
mention that them in the quantum realm
suits like that's just awesome but also
to mentioning you said hey you got to
watch Ant Man in the wasp yes because
spoiler alert if you haven't seen I'm
assuming you've seen a man the wasps you
see women had a Hank Pym goes into the
quantum room to get his wife that's the
suit he's wearing and something for the
breakdown video answer matter I'm just
saying that he takes good they're
leading with the student that's what's
up geez we got to get this up before
everyone starts to harassing me on my
phone in a second is the Toledo it off
right now
let's get this up we'll talk more better
than Vitt that's how you tease people
and before we wrap this video up I would
like to have a patron of the day shout
out to a woman named Adelia Chamberlain
Italia I know you were very much looking
forward to the captain marble experience
where you live it seems like you kind of
live in a desert town that has a nice
movie theaters she said when she went to
watch Captain Marvel that she was the
only person in the theaters only person
no wonder this movie flopped at the box
office Delia I'm happy you're winning in
life I looked up your name it means you
know being Noble which is exactly what
you are now finally knew what being
noble meant I could add more to this
shout out for you I love you my dear
anyway guys what do you think of the end
game trailer keep a look out for our
breakdown you guys can subscribe to the
reject nation click that notification
bell follow us on patreon today